short-term renting is not a problem
long-term renting is a problem and
here's why it's a problem the property
that you're living in is going to go up
in value in the next 10 years
substantially and the landlord is going
to benefit from that not you so short
term I'm all about renting when you're
broke you should rent until you get
yourself straightened out don't buy a
house just because buying a house is a
good thing because it's not a good thing
when you're broke but longterm home
ownership stabilizes your largest line
item in your budget locks in your
monthly cost and you have this large
asset that is going up in value